[Musique]
la campagne de dépistage massif a
commencé doucement ce matin donc nous
espérons que la population répondra
nombreuses à cet appel et il sera temps
une fois cette opération terminée de
regarder si cela correspond à la fois a
besoin à la fois une attente le projet
tester un maximum des 270 mille
habitants de la communauté urbaine du
havre en cinq jours nous invitons le
maximum de havraise et de havrais
d'habitants de la communauté urbaine du
havre à venir se faire tester
parce que s'ils sont positifs ils vont
être un élément de la réponse collective
et donc de la lutte collective contre
l'épidémie y a pas d'immunité collective
on a cinquante sept mille morts on a
encore 14 mille cas par jour donc temps
que ce vaccin n'est pas là on doit
continuer de dette de faire preuve de
civisme de respecter les consignes et on
attend ce vaccin revanchard qui se
fabrique à -60 bon vous et moi au moins
si on n'y connaît rien aux vaccins on
connaît au moins deux trois trucs sur le
surgelé puisque on en consomme un bon
donc le vaccin qui dépend d'une chaîne
une telle chaîne du froid
eh ben ils m'inquiètent alors ce vaccin
ne me rassure pas pour autant je ne suis
pas médecin je ne suis pas
épidémiologistes je ne sais pas c'est
effectivement mélenchon en raison
souligné que la chaîne du froid c'est un
problème ou est-ce que conserver une
chaîne de froid moins 70 bah oui c'est
vrai il ne vous rassure pas
qui ça le vaccin non le vaccin j'aime
vacciner sans aucun problème donc il
vous rassure ah oui oui oui il en
tombera sur pas particulièrement mais le
vaccin j'ai pu il n'y a pas de problème
sa colère ne retombe pas parmi les
hôteliers les restaurateurs et autres
gérants de discothèques qui manifestent
actuellement à paris un rassemblement
statique esplanade des invalides avec
comme principale revendication je cite
laissez nous travailler je voudrais
surtout appelé chacun maintenant à la
responsabilité avant noël on a réussi à
stopper ce virus on voit qu'on atteint
maintenant un plateau il faudrait
surtout pas que ça redémarre et au
lendemain des fêtes de noël ça ce serait
un échec collectif dramatique pour nous
tous ne faut pas croire aujourd'hui
qu'on donne de l'argent aux
restaurateurs et combien même pour ceux
qui ont droit aux aides
ça passe d'un côté et ça ressort de
l'autre ça ne reste pas quand vous avez
trois mille euros de loyer qu'on vous
donne mille cinq cents balles fait
comment peut m'expliquer comment vous
faites tous les week-ends tous les
vendredis tous les samedis il ya des
soirées où il n'y a rien pas de
toilettes pas de sécurité ça se passe
c'est du sauvage ça peut plus durer
qu'on nous laisse qu'on nous laisse le
moyen de travailler de prouver que nous
on ne peut avoir une traçabilité qu'on
peut gérer le public comme peut assurer
la circulation du virus
les restaurateurs aujourd'hui vidée
vivent des moments qui sont terrible
terrible psychologiquement et terrible
économiquement donc nous allons
continuer à les accompagner mais vous
dira le 20 janvier c'est fini on rouvre
ya pas de difficultés ce serait prendre
un risque excessif de dire cela
valenciennes des policiers ont été
agressés par une quinzaine d'individus
ça s'est passé lors d'une intervention
sur un rodéo de voitures selon
l'observatoire national de la
délinquance
le nombre de policiers blessés en
mission est passé de 5000 630 en 2012 à
7399 l'année dernière + 30 % 7 ans et
l'on décompte déjà 5828 agressions
depuis le début de l'année le maître du
roman d'espionnage de john le carré est
décédé samedi soir à l'âge de 89 ans
j'émettrais masse parce qu'autrement
savez je ne respecterait pas les gestes
barrière voilà juste dire mon masque de
seconde
voilà